he probably should have had some
camouflage on there not just a giant
white bald head my name is star first
class stephen mason
i'm the senior jungle instructor for
jungle operation training course
at uh lightning academy in the 25th
anniversary division i've currently been
the senior instructor for
two plus years out there and i
specialize in
tracking and survival today we're going
to be going over some jungle
warfare movies to determine whether or
not they're real
[Music]
this movie is ridiculous because that
guy has the inability to talk just
because he's being pulled into something
he's like
[Music]
i would say that the only time that that
would ever happen
is uh never camouflaged
top would be better he would have been
leaving dinosaur sized tracks so a lot
of people when they think about tracking
they just think about like a footprint
on the ground
but uh that that's actually one of the
last things we look for
everything is so thick that you're
actually leaving most of your your
imprints
from like your knee to your shoulder and
that's where you're kind of maneuvering
around and bending leaves and turning
leaves and
leaving scratches so i mean he would
have done a significant amount of that
kind of stuff
walking in and out of there
teach um a lot about water sources and
the way to move about them
uh and use them to your advantage i
don't know that we teach
coming out of the water and shooting
people with a bow and arrow that makes
noise so we
like to use waterways to traverse them
so instead of having to walk through
like just for example that jungle in the
background that would be very taxing on
the body if you had to walk
you know a significant amount of
distance through that where we just
teach you to get in that waterway and
and move until you think you can get out
again and start walking
like like they're doing but i would
never say there's a scenario where you'd
have to like hide in the water
so if i was rambo in this situation i
would probably be in the rocks
where he was and that way if they do
start shooting you at least have cover
but once they come to you then then
that's it that's game over
i've been put in situations in the
jungle where they give you you know
a couple days or a week worth of
classroom environment and then they load
you up in the back
of a truck and they drop you off in the
jungle by yourself and
you have nothing besides a knife and a
machete for the next 10 to 14 days
survival isn't what people think it is
whenever they watch like bear grylls
you know like he he's excellent at it
but he had to have gotten to that point
but you just can't go into the woods and
be like i'm gonna survive and then crush
it i'm going to say
a 2 out of 10 10 out of 10 for awesome
this is a double feature
for god's sake just lean your head back
and open your mouth
that's pretty it's pretty outdated i
mean we all we all chuckle through all
of them but uh
when you know when when stuff actually
hits the fan your
brain reverts back to like oh my gosh i
saw this stupid video
and that might save my life so we do
teach how to collect rain water and
different types of leaves or bamboos if
you were to just
tilt your head back and open your mouth
you wouldn't get enough water to do
anything
so everyone talks about like the rule of
three so you can go three minutes
without air
three days without water three weeks
without food but that's a good thing
about the jungle there's water
everywhere
there's a lot of vines inside of jungles
that just are filled with water for that
tree
and if you can find those just cut that
in half and you have a couple quarts of
water but the rule of thumb for soldiers
is a quarter water an hour
if you're under a heavy workload your
best friend is your knight
look at nice getting serious a knife is
absolutely the most important tool and
knives are used for everything from
um you know building your shelter with
it just using it to sharpen things to
slash things to cut things it has to be
durable that's why we talk about
full tang blades meaning that like the
the the knife is the the full length of
the handle instead of just being
the blade and then a little bit goes
into the handle uh because you need to
be able to like put that into trees and
then bang a rock on it to split wood
um it just needs to be used for for
everything
[Music]
even though it's right above you you
probably would forget about security and
running back into the woods so it
actually was time to get
you know picked up and uh at this point
he's just
trying to live he did exactly what uh we
we teach soldiers to do if you need to
get
found in a general environment you'd
find a big open area and try to try to
create something that's
larger than yourself so you could be
signaled you could light a fire and then
put a lot of green leaves on it will
create a big plume of white smoke
[Music]
not the jungle penetrator we actually
use that here at jungle school
same technology from vietnam we're still
using today because it's effective
authenticator what's your authentication
rescue
rescue dog that's very realistic so
whenever you deploy you have to fill
out some forms and there's a sequence of
questions that you have to answer in
case this scenario does happen you even
have to put like where your tattoos are
on your body and
um so when you do get caught they you
know they're making sure they're picking
up the right person and not someone they
don't want to be picking
up that's the that's the thing about the
jungle is that it can start breaking you
down
physically within 24 hours and you can
look like this within a week
and it all depends on your skill set and
how long you can survive
like me i think i could survive pretty
much indefinitely i would say
that the last scene that that's probably
a 10 out of 10.
be a fake human being maybe i can see
something i don't yet see or
learn something i don't yet now this is
my absolute
favorite jungle scene in any movie
that's ever been produced
because this sums up what it's like to
be in the jungle
1 000 you are just wet and miserable and
you're wondering the entire time
why you made this life choice oliver
stone the guy that made this movie he
was actually in the 25th entry and
deployed
with them to vietnam
it's usually pretty pretty dark inside
there i've been in a lot of jungles
where you can't even see your hand in
front of your face
uh during night operations kind of looks
like you know they have a spotlight on
top of them
you just have to be good at being
uncomfortable
there's no uh trick to that trade so
actually the
uh the 25th we are they were the first
ones to fill the new jungle uniforms a
little bit lighter weight they dry out
faster
we have jungle we have jungle boots that
uh that dry out quicker
i'm gonna be up scanning for every
little movement or sound i can so that
that keeps me up and i think that uh
you know just the the fear of everything
that's crawling around on the ground
while you're down there on it also keeps
you up
50 of everything is trying to kill you
whether it be the plant life or animal
in vietnam they have like 15 different
poisonous snakes
double that in poisonous spiders and
then they have tarantulas
so uh yeah you're just constantly on the
lookout for what you don't want to step
on sleep on or grab
and another thing is there's only one
person up on guard on this patrol and
that's nev would never happen
so in vietnam the average gunfight
firefight was within five to ten meters
so the enemy was it was able to get very
close
to us but we were also able to get very
close to the enemy stealth in the jungle
is paramount to probably anything else
you actually use
the same things today as you did back
then so technology has advanced a lot so
the jungle really hasn't
doesn't give you that capability because
uh it satellites can't penetrate through
it the night vision can't get through
there because i was talking about how
it's dark so night vision actually needs
ambient light to work so you need a
little little bit of light to make night
vision work
[Applause]
so when you get shot if you're still in
in that type of environment and
you know you're still you haven't won
the battle yet you have to
figure out kind of how to deal with the
pain like you said so that you're not
giving away your position because you
don't know if the enemy
uh has left the area yet actually a lot
of people when they get hit they don't
even realize they get hit because their
adrenaline's just pumping and they're
just
so ready for it and then someone
actually has to tell them like hey man
you know you got shot
i've personally seen that absolutely i
would give this a 10 out of 10
just because this reminds me of every
squad i've ever been in
he probably should have had some
camouflage on there not just a giant
white bald head keep your eye on the
package
roger that holding what was uh accurate
about this
is that they put a guy a sniper up top
who was kind of like their top side
security overwatch who was who was you
know watching the scenario unfold who
had comes with them who could say
you know like hey this the situation has
changed don't go in the fact that you
have to get all the way
up to the village very stealthily and
then try to work your way in one
building
at a time that's that's pretty accurate
if you were gonna go do something like
that
an operation like that you would be
camoed head to toe but
also them using suppressors that's
that's pretty accurate
you would use hand and arm signals a lot
uh moving around the jungle a lot of
them is just kind of like the
you know pulp stop uh keep moving
standard stuff you know these these
stuff like that
that's about that's about it uh using
rally points and pointing places saying
that you know like hey this
this is something significant you're
gonna have uh communication on you but
uh
so they have this this cool guy stuff
with you know an earpiece they even have
uh stuff that this like throat
mic so you can just press on your throat
you can whisper and it still comes
across
on the other end just as loud so yeah
everything's pretty accurate other than
the face paint
i would give this a 9 out of 10.
as soon as they made contact they
immediately rolled into the ditch and
then returned fire they got behind the
nearest cover and started returning fire
what was funny is that they were just
walking kind of in a straight line
across this open danger area which
wouldn't have happened could have done
another number of methods you could have
bounded
across it or you could have we call it
hand railing where you just kind of like
stay on the wood line and go through and
then that way you know
you wouldn't have been an open target it
is funny that he gets on the radio and
just starts calling in and then
rounds just start dropping doesn't even
give a grid doesn't tell him where he's
that just says tree line
you're in the woods and someone's like
we're in the tree line let's go
[Music]
so i'm not sure that the term pull back
is an army term
we would say break contact we'd have
somebody covering our fire while another
group
gets out of town and then once they get
to where they're going to go they'll
turn around start shooting and then
the next group leaves i don't think i've
ever seen a situation where someone
yells pull back and then everyone just
starts running in the opposite direction
so the responsibility of the leader is
to command and control the entire
situation
at no point unless it's like worst case
scenario should
the leader of the entire patrol be
picking people up and running with them
he should be delegating those tasks
uh and then you know relaying all the
information to hire and giving out
guidance
i would give this a six out of ten
after you've been in there a while you
can start to tell you know the
the weight of a say a tiger isn't the
weight of a human so you'll
be able to distinguish the tube plus a
tiger knows how to step and a human
doesn't
any any snap or crack you hear you're
going to automatically be on high alert
especially if you think the enemy's in
the area
[Music]
if i had a minigun in the jungle i would
be doing that with it so that's about as
accurate as this scene someone might
have an m16 and they're just
blasting off rounds and it's just coming
out as fast as the trigger can go and uh
they'd never do a magazine change and
he'll be in this firefight for like 20
minutes
yeah some of the weaponry was correct
but you would definitely not be lugging
around this gatling gun in the middle of
the jungle
those rounds that he had for the amount
of firepower that he put down that had
been like
hundreds of pounds so the goal is to be
as light as you can for the for the
longest
period that you can you need to be very
like aerodynamic and nimble i would rate
this
a 2 out of 10 but a 10 out of 10 for
awesome
this movie is based on one of the
battalions here in the 25th it's based
off 127 if tree the wolf hounds from
their charlie company
and this is when they had to be deployed
to guadalcanal this is a
the type of terrain you'd see when
you're coming out of the jungle and
getting into kind of like the
mountainous terrain where it's just like
a bunch of overgrown grass but they're
trying to do a frontal assault up
up a hill which was dumb in the first
place
probably wouldn't have happened not
really sure why he had a grenade
taped to his belt yeah normally you
won't be able to just pull the pin
itself
and the grenades still be on your body
the the distance was right the
the scenario was right just the way that
uh it was executed probably wouldn't
happen in real life
this is a pretty realistic war movie i
mean even all the way down to the way
that soldiers act whenever someone gets
hurt it's still just
a bunch of guys trying to figure it out
i would give
the scene a 7 out of 10 for realism
i want you to give me all the air
support get me on that now
i'll speak convenient that they had a
few helicopters and an airplane on
station within like a second of the
phone call going out for the radio
transmission and they didn't even like
have the grid out yet they were like
still talking and they were starting to
shoot
so the reason that they're using
helicopters and we decided to use
helicopters during vietnam
is because uh one of the only methods to
truly infill and exfilt from that type
of environment is to find that one
little clearing
and then try to get as many troops
rallied at the same point so that you
can
push push from there the vietnamese
clearly knew that that was going to be a
point that they would
try to infill and then they were dug
into the
into the side of the jungle mountain and
then just decided to fight down from
there
everything would be accurate as soon as
they as soon as they hit the ground they
just started
uh they started running to the nearest
cover which was
pretty far away because they got dropped
in the middle of the large field this is
based off a a real event
this colonel hal moore in the first cav
so when a helicopter is coming down
their entire body is spinning and then
they're kind of like
uh oscillating all around so you you
don't even know really where it's going
to land so you just don't even your hope
that you would just run in the right
direction but as far as being in that
helicopter
that's just kind of hold on and hope for
the best i would give this
a 10 out of 10 because i can i can
visualize what it would have been like
to be in this scenario and i just
feel bad for everyone that had to go
through this
so i love this scene a lot because
they're about to shoot a mortar
and they're about to do it um with uh
without a sight on it
and that's not the correct way that you
do it and then whenever they actually
hang the round and then shoot it it
immediately blast
uh you see the blast so the time of
flight would have been like the
same as just a regular bullet a way a
mortar works so it has to come out go in
the air and then come down and hit
that's not happening in this scene also
i think that they're giving corrections
without a sight on there
so i'm not sure what they're exactly
correcting but uh
that wouldn't happen this little tank
running around the battlefield
somebody would have probably already
tried to take that guy out
that's pretty accurate to what it is
like to get uh to see a tank get shot by
another tank
we had shermans on shore at guadalcanal
uh and they were just trying to
reinforce
the the infantry but that that's kind of
the role of a tank in this situation is
just to
try to flush out you know all the larger
targets so that the ground forces can
continue to push forward but actually at
this stage of the war tanks weren't on
ground yet
because we just had just taken the beach
that's also super accurate all the
weapons are are pretty spot on the
equipment was spot on they're shooting
thompson's which is
accurate for for officers and that the
officer in this scene has a thompson
this is a good scene other than the
mortar i would also rate this a seven
out of ten
at the jeep designer sunglasses you sure
that's him
this looks like a kodak camera zoom i'm
not sure what that is
he's moving
[Music]
you're always going to have a spotter
and then you're going to have a sniper
and then they're going to be talking
back and forth about
you know distance and wind correction
so he just said two people
go walk down a hill uh i'm not really
sure what
why he did that especially since five
seconds ago they were talking to each
other in normal voices giving each other
corrections and then now they decide
they want to be stealthy and walk away
you never want to give up on stealth
just because of distance
first things i tell people about the
jungle especially at night time
it's almost so loud that it's unbearable
so the first night i spent inside of a
jungle i
this bird hadn't made the sound all day
and i didn't know what it was
but at nighttime i still don't even know
what type of bird it was it just sounded
like this man
that was just like being stabbed or
something it was just like this
ah and i couldn't i was like what is
happening and then all the other animals
start feeding off that and
it's just it's deafening how loud the
jungle is i would give this
a seven out of ten biggest thing that
people that movies get wrong about the
jungle is uh
how long it actually takes to maneuver
from one location to the next you know
you might watch a movie and it's like
they're just walking for days across the
jungle uh depending on the type of
environment you might only move a
football field's length 100 meters